African Americans are the fastest
growing voting Block in Georgia now
nearly 40 percent of the state's
electorate that's an increase of some
seven percent in two decades
other minority communities are growing
as well and these shifting demographics
had much to do with the traditionally
Red State turning blue
and people like Pastor Andre Osborne are
working to build on 2020's gains having
the right type of energy in an election
that's not a presidential election is
incredibly important so we're trying to
encourage people to vote every time but
voting regulations have changed
significantly since 2020 stung by their
losses the Republicans governing the
state past Senate Bill 202 which among
other restrictions requires voters to
provide a picture ID at the polling
place there is certainly of movement to
limit or drastically reduce the voice of
the people
by minimizing the impact of their vote
but the new law also expands early
voting which may have a result the
framers didn't intend it really depends
on how voters decide to turn out this
year do they decide to vote absentee in
that case the law would restrict them if
they decide to come out and vote in
person and do early voting the law may
actually help them and be on their side
The crucial Senate race sees the
incumbent Democrat Rafael Warnock up
against the Trump endorsed former
American football star Herschel Walker
whose campaign has been marked by
allegations of domestic violence and the
claim that The anti-abortion Advocate
actually paid for a partner's abortion I
thank every vote that her should get is
a vote against binding Biden it's not
like you know they just want somebody to
feel that see the main thing is to
defeat Republicans and keep them out of
power
thank you
[Music]
ultimately the result will be determined
by the size of the turnout at the poles
the larger the boat the greater the
possibility of a Democrat Party win
the reality is simple if the Democrats
do not win in Georgia they will in all
likelihood lose control of the house and
of the Senate and that will be an answer
to Republican prayers
Mike Hanna Al Jazeera Savannah